and we're here in the southern suburbs
just south of the city center where the
rubble of a missile has fallen and hit a
house just behind me this is where an
older man and his son were sleeping his
son was on the top floor he was on the
ground floor they said that the only
reason that they weren't hurt is because
of this wall between them where the
rubble of a missile fell and and hit the
house I mean this has been a period of
relative calm here in the Kiev region
most of the fighting has been
concentrated in the East and the south
of the country but today in what can
only be described as a retaliatory
attack from Russia the Air Force
intercepted 54 out of 69 missiles they
said rain down on the country the
officials say that 16 of those missiles
that were fired towards the key of
region all of them were intercepted and
what we see here is the the damage from
the falling Rubble I mean this attack
comes after videos were circulated on
Russian TV saying that they vowed
revenge against Ukraine after engel's
Arabic base was hit earlier this week
for the second time in just a few weeks
air Engels is a Strategic Air Base and
home to some of Russia's finest bombers
and being hit by Ukrainian drone was
very embarrassing for Russia and this
can only be deemed as a retaliation